- I watch you every fucking
morning on the treadmill
and I hate it.
(laughter)
And I'll tell you: 2016,
negative $25,000 in debt.
2017, made my first million
by applying your principles.
- Congratulations.
- [Man] Thank you.
- That's incredible.
I think that'd be a great
way to start a preview.
Then we've got...
I mean how clean would that look?
Yeah, I mean, that's just like absurd.
(electronic music)
Just landed in SFO and have to address
probably the most
important business question
I've ever asked my YouTube community.
Which one of these
stuffed animals is best?
Cool cutie, you see this
little puppy right here.
Little anime...
- [Man] Are you gonna buy one?
- No, but this pink monkey
is loving San Francisco.
("Free" by JPAULISHED)
I feel like we should ask Compass Books
if they're getting Crush again.
Do you think they'll mind?
Hey, I cleaned up a little big just now.
♪ Why can't we be free ♪
- I've just been not posting.
So busy.
It made me pick an arbitrary number.
Agent 2021.
Whether you go with that
route or something else,
I do think you have a positive versus,
kind of look forward versus backwards.
But it's about offense.
It's about throwing a flag in the ground
to the future, right?
I'm a big believer...
I just don't understand
when people name and brand
and market of them looking backwards,
or looking in the defense of it.
Like, you know, I'm just a...
People are always like,
we're gonna fix this this.
Or, you know, this was fucked up
and this is the We're Gonna
Clean Up The Fuck Up Tour
instead of, like, We're
Gonna Dominate 2025 Tour.
You know?
It's subtle, but it's real.
It's positivity versus negativity,
offense versus defense, you know?
♪ And then they act all surprised
they called it Kapernik ♪
- [Man] Gary, it's
wonderful to meet you, dude.
- It's a real pleasure.
- I'm 53 years old and I'm telling you,
I've learned more shit from
you than with a million people.
- Thank you so much, what's your name?
- I'm Edward.
- Thank you man, I appreciate it.
What you do is more important.
- Thank you, my friend.
Thank you.
♪ They try to take us down ♪
- Let's get more of a strategist.
Who's in the audience for the keynote?
♪ Why can't we be free ♪
♪ 'Cause that's the way
that it's supposed to be ♪
- Follow Fridays was fun.
We could bring back Follow Friday.
Actually, you know what,
I have a great idea.
If you send a text to the team.
I think kids should go
work for people for free,
and keep it humble for
the first three years.
Free to as little as possible,
I think every one of you in this room
should live in the same
one bedroom apartment
but work for the best person
you can get in front of for free.
'Cause the IP, the intelligence.
Like you can read books
about how to play basketball,
but until you get on the court, the fuck?
And that's what's happening, and so...
Yeah, I'm not trying to be Debbie Downer,
I just want practicality
back in the system,
because I think a lot of...
You have to understand, people
wrap their self-esteem up
in their business.
You start a new business, you're 24,
you're telling your mom,
you're telling your homies,
you're like I got this business
and you're fucking flashing it,
and you put entrepreneur in
the title of your Instagram,
and you're on blast now.
And when it fails, all your
self-esteem goes with it.
And I want to remind
everybody, 99% are gonna fail.
This isn't 50.
So like, everybody who said,
"Yeah, yeah, but I'm gonna break through."
Cool, but like 99% are gonna fail,
plus the economy has been phenomenal
for 9 years in a row
now, so all the kids...
You've got to be 32 to even, basically,
kind of remember when shit was bad.
So if you're under 32,
you've never been punched
in the fucking mouth.
So you don't even know the difference,
you think it's just always
going to be like this.
You don't know what it really looks like.
You're not winning and building a business
during easy times,
the fuck is gonna happen
when no money is around?
So I'm concerned, but I'm optimistic.
I just wish people got
real with themselves.
♪ Why can't we be free ♪
- Awesome!
- The story of this, how he
found me is like, you know
"Hey, who's looking for a...
"I'm the director of GaryVee so...
"I want to be a director for somebody."
- And I hit him up and I was like,
"Hey, I'm recording Gear tonight,
"you wanna roll through?"
And he's like, he drove out here, so.
- Uh, vlog?
We just did a fun podcast,
we're here about to give a keynote,
getting a lot of work done on email,
it's all good stuff.
♪ To be free but police
says there's no way ♪
♪ Times they don't change ♪
♪ The country swervin off
the road from the roadway ♪
♪ We got to change that
and do what they said ♪
♪ 'Cause I don't see where
the fucking humor's at ♪
♪ Throw your hands up in the sky ♪
(audience applause)
- Really something that fascinates me,
because we think a lot
about money and opportunity,
let me tell you about an opportunity
that I can't get out of my head.
Which is, there's a
website called Craigslist,
there's a section called Free,
where people list shit that
they want to get rid of.
You go there and you take it,
and then you list it on
Facebook Marketplace,
and you sell it.
And when I think about this, I can't...
I've been dreaming about
this for the last 72 hours,
by the way,
I'm literally doing this
selfishly so DRock captures this,
'cause this videos going out.
You know, it's crazy to me
that the only thing that
stops somebody from winning,
is education and the work ethic, right?
I understand that.
But education comes in
so many different forms.
This is a classroom of 16 year olds,
and they have to make
money in the next 24 months
or bad, bad stuff happens.
I only default into go
buy shit and sell it,
and run the internet arbitrage,
we'll spend the first three months,
I'll teach you everything
about Craigslist and eBay,
and Facebook Marketplace, and LetGo,
and then we'll talk about
China and buying shit there,
and the arbitrage,
I would spend an enormous amount of time
because the practicality right now
in the inefficiency of the internet
of buying and selling
stuff is extraordinary.
In the last three weeks,
I've had these kids
who have been following my content
and they're like, "Gary,
I wanna get your advice,"
and basically, both narratives
went the exact same way
which is, hey, I listened to you,
I got good, I started buying stuff,
then I hit it big.
A bunch of people made a lot of money
on the solar eclipse glasses,
like you could literally buy those things
for like 16 cents in China on Baidu
and then sell it for
like $4 a pop on Amazon.
People made bank.
Like I know one kid who made $317,000.
(crowd murmuring)
On a $3,000 starting point, right?
So, it's very real to me,
instead of "I'm gonna build some crazy app
"that's gonna fucking
change the world," right?
'Cause it's practical as fuck.
And both of them have made real money,
one kids made like $60,000 this year,
off of like a hundred dollar base.
Like real money, and
both of them took it all
and bought crypto.
- [Audience Member] Woo!
- [Gary] Yes, yes.
(laughter)
And by the way, I believe in
blockchain as a technology
out my ass.
The part of the story he doesn't know
is they bought at $17,000, right?
(crowd groans)
And they bought at $17,000
because they read 400 articles
that said it was gonna be $34,000
and by the way, Bitcoin could be $400,000.
I'm not sure, I don't know.
Here's what I'm disappointed in:
Short-term thinking.
When he goes, "Woo," I'm not mad at him.
I'm like, listen, maybe, long-term.
I don't know anybody's money situation.
Let me give you something
that will really work for you.
If you don't have to take
it out of Wall Street,
put your money into Facebook and Amazon,
and I promise you, unless America melts
over the next seven to
10 years, you'll do well.
There's certain things
that are just so black
and white obvious, right?
And then everybody else is
looking for a lottery ticket.
I used that analogy in
a podcast I just did
with some good guys.
And it hit me, maybe
because I was in Miami
and stayed at The Hard
Rock Casino fucking hotel,
which was fucking disgusting,
but a lot of people are
treating their business
the way you go to a casino.
Yeah, you could have one night
where you took 5,000 from the casino,
but why don't you keep going every night
and tell me how it works out?
They don't build Vegas on us winning,
and everybody's treating their
business that way right now.
Everybody's jumping from trend to trend,
they have no foundation of
what they're actually doing,
they're riding only headlines,
and they're gonna get exposed.
Instead of taking a meaningful step back
and doing a lot of thinking about:
A: How exciting it is to eat shit.
You know, the thing that works for me
that I really wished on everybody else
is I love the journey, I love the game.
I love the struggle.
- That was amazing, thank you.
That was amazing.
And I loved that audience.
- I think the biggest
impact I'm having is,
there's a fuckload of 16
year old boys right now
who think I'm the coolest,
and I'm telling them to
stop buying fucking Supremes
and stop disrespecting women,
and start fucking being
patient, and being kind,
and I think my impact on that
is gonna be disproportionate
to writing checks.
- Right.
- Okay, I'm thrilled to have that convo.
- Good to meet you.
- Good meeting you man.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
- Thank you.
- Life is good man, you
did a really nice shot.
I really mean that,
I don't throw around compliments so easy.
I was really, really,
really fucking impressed
with your presentation, it was real good.
- GaryVee, baby.
- What up, baby, how are you?
Good?
- I watch you every fucking
morning on the treadmill
and I hate it,
I gotta tell you:
2016, negative $25,000 in debt.
2017, made my first million
by applying your principles.
Real estate will not die.
- Love you brother, congratulations.
That's incredible.
- [Man] Thank you!
♪ Throw your hands up in the sky ♪
♪ If you human ♪
♪ That means everybody living ♪
- [Gary] How many?
- [Woman] For one, at
least one a month, now.
More than that?
- [Gary] I did one a day,
and I had an audience.
Thank you guys, thank you, got it?
That is the absolute quickest way, 100%.
- [Woman] What about,
what about like our guest?
What do you think about that?
- [Gary] That works too, of course.
It's siphoning off of
people's equity, right?
Okay, bye guys, thank you.
Bye guys, thank you for having me.
Alright, what do you think, DRock?
♪ Why can't we be free ♪
♪ 'Cause that's the way
that it's supposed to be ♪